[موسيقى]
عن استهداف سفينه امريكيه او مملوكه لشركه
امريكيه بالصواريخ ورمى الحوثيون الكره في
الملعب الامريكي اخيرا باستهداف سفينه
نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه عمليه استهداف لسفينه كيم رينجر
الامريكيه سوناك يصرح هجمات الحوثيين
تسببت باضطراب هائل للاقتصاد العالمي وفي
الطرف الاخر بايدن يعلن عن استمرار
الضربات في اليمن ليرد زعيم الحوثيين
ويعلن التحدي باستهداف سفينتين جديدتين
فيما السفن التجاريه العالميه ترضخ لشروط
الحوثيين المكسيك والتشيلي تلحق بجنوب
افريقيا في الجنائيه الدوليه لمقاضاته
واداره بايدن تبخ الحكومه العبريه
النتنياهو يوقف صفقه لتبادل الاسرى والجيش
العبري يعلن ساعه الصفر في الحدود
اللبنانيه حكومه تل ابيب ترفض مقترحا
امريكيا للتطبيع مع السعوديه ومصر تتوقف
عن دفع دين كبير مستحق لتل ابيب بيكين
تتدخل لتهدئه التوتر بين باكستان وايران
واوكرانيا تقترب من استنفاد مخزون
وزيلينسكي يلجا للرئيس الصيني وقنابل
فرنسا تسلك طريقها باتجاه
كياف معارك البحر
الاحمر المعارك البحريه لا تتوقف والبحر
الاحمر ساحه للصراع جديد حيث كانت وكاله
بلومبرج تحدثت عن ان سفنا تجاريه رضخت
لشروط الحوثيين وبثت عباره لا علاقه لنا
بتل ابيب في محاوله لتجنب هجمات الحوثيين
قبل ذلك كان الجيش الامريكي اعلن توجيهه
ضربات استهدفت 14 منصه صواريخ للحوثيين
كانت جاهزه لاطلاق قذائفها وشكلت تهديدا
للسفن التجاريه والسفن البحريه الامريكيه
في المنطقه حتى ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن جدد القول ان الضربات الامريكيه
البريطانيه التي تستهدف الحوثيين في اليمن
ستستمر ما داموا يوصلون هجماتهم على سفن
في البحر الاحمر في وقت اعلن فيه البيت
الابيض شن ضربات جديده على مواقع للحوثيين
ليخرج وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي لافروف
ويقول ان المبررات امريكيه لشن ضربات على
اليمن وهنا فيما كان الرد الحوثي باعلان
هيئه بحريه بريطانيه انها تلقت بلاغا
جديدا عن حادثه على بعد 115 ميلا بحريا
جنوب شرق عدن كما قال مصدر عسكري يمني
لقناه الجزيره ان قوات الحوثيين استهدفت
سفينه امريكيه بالقرب من سواحل المكله
اليمنيه من جهتها اعلنت شركه امبري للامن
البحري ان ناقله مملوكه للولايات المتحده
وترفع علم جزر مارشال ابلغت عن اقت راب
اربعه مسيرات منها بشكل مريب جنوب شرقي
المكله وكان زعيم الحوثيين عبد الملك
الحوثي قال في خطاب للشعب اليمني ان
العمليات في البحر الاحمر سيتم توسيعها
لتشمل السفن البريطانيه والامريكيه مؤكدا
ان الضربات التي تنفذها الدولتان لن تغير
موقف جماعته ليعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريتشي سوناك ان هجمات الحوثيين تسببت
باضطراب هائل للاقتصاد العالمي وها هو
المصدر امامكم ان زياده الهجمات على السفن
التجاريه غير قانونيه وتسبب اضطرابا هائلا
للاقتصاد العالمي قضائيا كانت وزاره
الخارجيه المكسيكيه اعلنت ان المكسيك
وتشيلي تحيل وضع دوله فلسطين الى المدعي
العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه للتحقيق
في جرائم محتمله واضافت الوزاره ان
الاجراء سببه تزايد القلق بشان تصاعد
العنف مؤخرا خاصه ضد الاهداف المدنيه في
القطاع وهنا نتصفح
المصدر
لكن هنا كان رئيس الوزراء العبري
النتنياهو شدد على انه لا يمكن ان يسمح
بقيام دوله فلسطينيه ما دام في منصبه من
جهه اخرى قالت القناه 13 العبريه ان
الامريكيين ابلغوا تل ابيب ان عدد
المدنيين غير المتورطين مازال مرتفعا رغم
الانتقال لمرحله اقل كثفه حيث تشير
احصاءات الى مقتل 150 مدنيا يوميا في
القطاع واضافت القناه ان مسؤولين بارزين
بطاره بايدن وبخوا العبريين بسبب استمرار
ارتفاع عدد القتلى المدنيين هناك دعى
الرئيس العبري اسحاق هرتسوغ الدول القويه
الى تشكيل تحالف لاعاده اعمار القطاع بعد
انتهاء الحرب مع الفصائل مشيرا ان
العبريين لا يريدون التفكير في السلام مع
القطاع اثناء استمرار الحرب فيما قالت
القناه 14 العبريه ان النتنياهو عرقل في
الايام الاخيره مقترحا لصفقه تبادل اسر
ساخه وزراء مجلس الحرب اما القناه السابعه
العبر فنقلت عن وزير الامن القومي ايثمار
بن غفير قوله ان النتنياهو يرتكب اخطاء
واذا توقفت الحرب فلن تكون هناك حكومه
واليكم المصدر ما دلالات ان يقوم وزراء في
مجلس الحرب بصياغه مقترح لتبادل الاسرى في
هذه المرحله وان يقوم بالموزه نتنياهو
بعرق ذلك الامر على حدود لبنان قال رئيس
اركان الجيش العبري هارت سي هاليفي خلال
تفقده مناوره عسكريه قرب الحدود مع لبنان
ان احتمالا نشوب حرب مع لبنان ازداد
مقارنه بالماضي وهنا يتحدث المصدر هذه
التصريحات حول احتمال نشوب حرب في الجبهه
الشماليه من المسؤولين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين فيما اجرى وزير الدفاع
العبري افغان تقييما للاوضاع المدنيه وركز
على جاهزيه الساحه الشماليه لاحتمال توسيع
المواجهه مع لبنان ولننتقل الى مصر حيث
قالت اذاعه كان احد عشر العبريه ان مصر
توقفت عن دفع دين كبير مستحق لتلبي بسبب
الحرب على القطاع مضيفه ان القاهره توقفت
عن تحويل اموال تعويضات الغاز الطبيعي الى
الكيان بواقع 30 مليون دولار وبين هذا
وذاك ذكرت شبكه ان بي سي ان نتنياهو رفض
اقتراح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن التطبيع بين تل ابيب والسعوديه
مقابل قيام دوله فلسطينيه وفي ذات السياق
قالت السفيره السعوديه لدى الولايات
المتحده الاميره ريما بنت بندر ال سعود من
مؤتمر دافوس ان لا محادثات تطبيع مع تلبيب
قبل انتهاء الحرب في القطاع وبعيدا عن حرب
القطاع وبعض الضربات المتبادله عند الحدود
بين ايران وباكستان بما في ذلك ضربه قالت
ايران انها اودت بحياه سبعه اشخاص اعربت
بكين عن استعدادها للتوصل بين البلدين
وقالت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
مونينج في مؤتمر صحفي دوري نحن على
استعداد للاعب دور بناء في خفض التصعيد في
حال رغب الطرفان بذلك اعتراف
اوكراني ضعف غير مسبوق في الجبهه
الاوكرانيه ليصرح الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي معترفا بانه لا يوجد
انتاج عسكري في العالم كله يكفي اوكرانيا
لتحمل حرب ضد الجيش الروسي وكان منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض
جون كوربي قال ان اوكرانيا في ظل غياب
المساعده الامريكيه تقترب من استنفاذ
مخزونها من الاسلحه فيما رفض رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي مايك جونسون ضمان موافقه
الكونجرس على استمرار المساعدات لاوكرانيا
مؤكدا اهميه متابعه وجهه المليارات
المصروفه على ورسم استراتيجيه واضحه لهذا
الدعم وذلك في حديث لقناه سي ان ان هذا
واعلن وزير الدفاع الفرنسي سيباستيان ل
كورنو اليوم الخميس ان بلاده تعتزم تزويد
اوكرانيا ب 50 قنبله اي اي اس ام جواله
شهريا اعتبارا من يناير ولمده عام ول
نتصفح المصدر
امامكم من جهته صرح ضابط الاستخبارات
الامريكيه السابق سكوت ريتر ان الغرب ان
يتخذ اجراءات انتحاريه من اجل انقاذ
اوكرانيا محذرا زيلنسكي من مصيره القادم
هناك لجات اوكرانيا الى الصين حيث ذكرت
صحيفه بلومبرج نقلا عن وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا ان كياف تسعى الى
تنظيم محادثه هاتفيه مع الرئيس الصيني
شيجين بينغ فما الذي سيطلبه زيلينسكي من
تشي من جهته افاد الضابط المتقاعد في
الجيش الامريكي ايرل راس ماسون بان
استهداف روسيا للعديد من المقاتلين
المرتزقه الفرنسيين في خاركوف الاسبوع
الماضي هو تحذ للاشخاص الذين يفكرون في
العمل لحسابهم الخاص في الجيش الاوكراني
يجب ان يتوقعوا ان يعاملوا مثل المقاتلين
المحليين بحسب وكاله سبوتنك في الداخل
الاوكراني صرح نائب البرلمان الاوكراني
جيو ليروس على مدونته على يوتيوب ان رئيس
اوكرانيا يسرق بوقاحه ميزانيه الدوله
ووفقا لصحيفه بوليتيكو فان البيط الابيض
يشعر بقلق اكبر بشان مشكله الفساد في
اوكرانيا ما يعترف به على المستوى العام
ليخرج وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديميتري
كوليبا ويؤكد بلومبرغ انه لا يمكن ان تكون
كياف تسرق اموال دفع الضرائب الامريكيين
مشيرا الى ان معظم الاموال الامريكيه تبقى
في امريكا وتستخدم لانتاج الاسلحه هناك
وميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تحرير بلده فيسو في جمهوريه دونيسك
الشعبيه والقضاء على اكثر من 860 عسكريا
اوكرانيا واسقاط 91 مسيره اطلقتها قوه
كياف على مختلف المحاور خلال
يوم